okay I'm not girl uh D I was thinking I
want to do a video but what do I want to
do a video on oh man it's so cool the
Grand Admiral thrones coming back man I
want to do a video oh that's really cool
of thrones coming back let me think of a
video to do so why not talk about the
fact that Grand Admiral Thrawn is coming
back it's awesome and the Star Wars
Curtain Cape today because you can't you
cannot expend the currency of the
curtain cape too much you can't show it
too much by mister Wars nothing but
stuff would those be you don't know this
is my old Star Wars curtain from when I
was a child now I wear it when I talk
about Star Wars ish things here why this
is so awesome art we have to go back to
a time before there were Star Wars
prequels before we called it the
original trilogy we just had Star Wars
movies we had the Star Wars trilogy
because that's all we had and the
continuing Adventures of Star Wars took
place in the form of novels by various
authors one author in particular became
a huge fan favorite his name is Timothy
Zahn wrote arguably the best books test
of the old Star Wars books there were
still fan favorites when Disney was like
nope it never happened now fans were
like yeah but the Timothy Zahn books are
good so they're still good and he
created a couple of fan favorite
characters Mara Jade and Grand Admiral
Thrawn Mara Jade
as of now still not Canon but Grand
Admiral Thrawn is being brought on to
the canonical pedestal because fans love
him to death and he is rad and now he's
canon he's real he happens among the
Star Wars universe to be clear that
Timothy Zahn books are still fanfiction
they didn't officially happen for the
force awakens to happen that can't have
happened but Grand Admiral Thrawn is
gonna be brought into the animation Star
Wars rebels season 3 as the main
antagonist but I think of a Star Wars
rebels I watched the first couple
episodes and I was like yeah it's not
really grabbing me I don't have to watch
and one of the people I don't have to do
everything Star Wars to feel like a Star
Wars fan I love the movies I love some
of the games I have loved the movies
will the original trilogy all of my life
I just didn't feel like I needed to
watch the animations they didn't grip me
but I still have my movies but
admittedly at a point I was channel
surfing and the season finale of Star
Wars rebels season 2 came on I was like
alright I'm gonna watch this let's see
what happens and what I saw was pretty
awesome I gotta say so at that
point I wanted to go back and watch
rebels seasons 1 & 2 now the thrones
coming in for season 3 I just play in
half to everybody who don't know who
Grand Admiral throw
is or why this is super awesome a Grand
Admiral Thrawn just super smart
brilliant cultured master tactician he's
like if Tywin Lannister and Tyrion
Lannister had a lovechild together
Grand Admiral Thrawn bit of a weird
analogy I probably should have said
Tywin Lannister with a better childhood
but I feel like in a war of tactics I
feel like drawn could kick Tywin's ass
so that doesn't really work if hannibal
lecter from the show Hannibal had a kid
with Khan maybe Tyrion Lannister and
Khan's point is Grand Admiral Thrawn is
in the hierarchy of the tactician 'he's
that we have seen certainly the best
we've seen in Star Wars and I can't wait
to see what he does to make history in
the Canon the official storytelling we
have for Star Wars and the rebels
trailer there before it revealed him
they were like this they know all of our
attacks and know what we're gonna do
there why they're adapting way too fast
who is this man behind the curtain Oh
another thing that makes him really cool
is like the Empire has a strong
prejudice against aliens like all
they're all technically aliens to us so
they don't really let aliens reach the
officer ranks Grand Admiral Thrawn is a
Grand Admiral and he isn't alien he is a
Chiss because the emperor was like now
you you're good at your job what is fine
cherry on top Grand Admiral Thrawn is
getting a book called yes Thrawn written
by the one who created Grand Admiral
Thrawn Timothy Zahn Timothy Zahn created
throne Timothy's I try to say that
that's hard yes Timothy Zahn is writing
the book throne I actually got Tarkin
for free last year at Comic Con still
haven't read it I want to because I love
Grand Moff Tarkin but I haven't read it
I'm probably gonna read wrong because I
love dudes like throne I just do I love
super brilliant Imperial types who were
just too much for the rebels it's like
yeah you're better than us I don't know
what to say we're probably going to lose
this fight because of you that's Ron in
a nutshell
expect to go down funny thing is
among all of this only gripe I've
actually heard is the fact that Grand
Admiral Thrawn has pupils yeah like the
chest their eyes were all red and now is
everything you've seen of Grand Admiral
Thrawn like in the trailer for rebel
season 3 on the cover of the book it's
all read but he does have pupils I feel
like it's a humanizing thing like
everything is pupils now like
transformers have pupils in the movies
Ultron had pupils just everything has to
have pupils just kind of a thing a mode
we're in right now and I really think
it's due to it being seen as a
humanizing feature you know eyes are the
gateway to the soul kind of thing even
when James Cameron was creating avatar
it was one of the things where he was
like all CGI characters always have dead
eyes and it just drives me mad so it's
one of the things he wanted to do in
making avatar he wanted to just capture
their faces including their eye
movements because eyes are just what
make things look alive or not and so I
feel like that's why he's going to have
pupils just it's gonna be a little more
humanizing plus you can just kind of
glare out of the corner of his eye and
you know he's doing it I mean if
everything's just red he's getting glare
it's just gonna look like staring like
this like oh I hate you so much you
anyhow man that's what I just wanted to
say that because it was it was a really
sad time when the old books as much as I
understood why they were wiped away and
why they had to be declared non
canonical it was a sad time when it
happened because Grand Admiral Thrawn
was just such a beloved character it's a
shame to lose that character so now Han
glad they're like now he still happens
so when you watch your Star Wars movies
when you watch your Empire Strikes Back
know that thron happened in that
universe you're like Ron's gonna die
down he's in Star Wars rebels he is not
in the original trilogy so he dies
somewhere in between he's not in rogue
one we haven't seen him that we know of
it's possible that he's going to be in
the movie we just don't know it but I
don't think it's gonna be the case so
thrones gonna die somewhere in rebels
doesn't have to be season 3 can be in
season 3 4 5 whatever but he's gonna die
there oh he's in rogue one and he's just
wearing face makeup like Jack
Nicholson's junker did in the original
lid the Burton Batman that guy's throne
or something I'm just probably not I'm
just saying for the sake of sainte which
is 90 percent of the reason people say
anything all right guys so Grand Admiral
Thrawn is coming back he is back baby he
is canon he is gonna be a Star Wars
rebels
he's getting his own book written by
Timothy Zahn dad what a time to be alive
but guys what do you think about this
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more